I would give it an award...
...for the best...
...outer space movie?
Marlowe
what do you think the movie'sabout?
The movie is about a girlnamed Fei Fei
and she's trying to save Chang'e's life.
How does she build a rocket to the moon?
She takes a bunch of stuff people don't
need anymore and she builds a rocket ship.
The moon is like really far away from
earth. Like it's really really far away.
It would probably take 15 hours.
Probably more than2,000 minutes.
That'd be a long time.
Yeah.
I would love to know what your favorite scene was?
When shegets to go to the moon
they had a big dance party.
Marlowe do you have a favorite song?
I like the one when they're making the mooncakes.
♪ Stuff! Roll! Press! Smack! ♪
Stuff! Roll! Press! Smack!
Would you recommend this to your friends?
i would recommend this movie to my friends.
Most to my friends like outer space
and trying to do stuff that they can't do.
They say "I can't do this but i'm gonnatry"
Marlowe, do you know what an Oscar is?
Mmhmm.
Wait actually i don't.
An Oscar is an award that
they give for movies.
Um, okay.
I think this movie deserves an Oscar.
It teaches people that theycould
do things even though they don't know they can..
Why did you think of making the movie?
Themoon goddess she's very famous in china.
We thought it would be really fun to share
her story withkids all around the world.
Do you think Fei Fei really went
to the moon and came back?
I don'tthink Fei Fei was dreaming.
I think it actually happened.
The ending made me feel happy.
Thank youMarlowe!
Thank you Marlowe, you were awesome.
It's so nice to meet you.
Bye!